notre collègue Françoise Ferrat pourrait
elle aussi
c'est
la dernière question
après un mandat qui a commencé en 2001
comme sénateur de la Marne notamment
investi sur les enjeux ruraux et
agricoles au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques je voudrais citer
mes chers collègues le rapport qu'elle a
fait avec Henri cavanel et rapport sur
la détresse et les suicides en
agriculture qui doit nous amener me
semble-t-il à réfléchir collectivement
sur la situation du parti de notre
population qui a parfois le sentiment
qu'on ne prend pas suffisamment compte
ce qu'elle représente pour notre pays
vraiment je vous la remercier pour cet
engagement dans notre assemblée
vous avez la parole madame la sénatrice
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues des constats persistants
témoignent de la baisse des compétences
des élèves français en mathématiques et
de désinfection pour les cursus
scientifiques
sachez que 80% des enfants en
Grande-Bretagne et en Allemagne ont des
activités scientifiques en dehors de
l'école nous n'en avons que 8% en France
la culture scientifique est pour tous
les citoyens pas seulement pour les
scolaires les Français reconnaissent
avoir confiance en la science les sujets
scientifiques réchauffement climatiques
nucléaire pandémie vaccin alimente la
réflexion et le débat mais aussi la
controverse et la suspicion
quelle place pour la science dans nos
sociétés abreuvées d'informations 24
heures sur 24 les enjeux mondiaux à
venir sont interdépendants de la science
et des avancées technologiques
l'ensemble de la population doit
disposer des codes et des clés pour
comprendre les enjeux fondamentaux qui
vont changer nos habitudes et nos
certitudes de plus la confusion entre
l'opinion et l'effet scientifique
constituent une menace pour la
démocratie et pour nos sociétés un
rapport de l'UNESCO sur la science
précise que les sciences la technologie
et l'innovation ont la capacité de
changer la donne pour relever
pratiquement tous les défis mondiaux les
plus urgents méditer cela mes chers
collègues ainsi la puissance
industrielle de la France que nous
appelons de nos vœux progressera avec
ses connaissances c'est pourquoi la
culture scientifique de se développer à
l'école mais aussi dans les médias pour
former les citoyens les sciences et les
mathématiques ne doivent pas être
ervées à une élite mais partagez auprès
du plus grand nombre pour développer
notre pays forger l'esprit critique le
raisonnement factuel et appréhender les
infox et théories complotistes monsieur
le ministre envisagez-vous pour
développer la culture scientifique en
France
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Françoise Ferrat ont aussi je
m'associe à l'hommage qui vient de vous
être chaleureusement rendu et je vous
remercie de votre proposition et me
réjouis qu'elle ait pu rassembler des
sénateurs de tous les bancs sur une
question d'évidence cruciale pour notre
pays nous sommes engagés dans une
stratégie qui vise à promouvoir la
culture scientifique dès le plus jeune
âge afin d'une part de renforcer les
compétences scientifiques des élèves
mais aussi de créer le goût pour les
mathématismes et les sciences exactes
avec notamment une priorité celle de
mobiliser les filles dans ces matières
cette stratégie n'aboutira que si nous
déconstruisons des représentations que
les élèves peuvent avoir des
mathématiques qui apparaissent souvent
comme difficiles ou trop élitiste comme
souligne très justement votre résolution
l'excellence scientifique française doit
concerner un plus grand nombre d'élèves
afin de construire leur esprit
scientifique et de lutter contre les
infox elle doit aussi permettre à notre
économie de pouvoir compter sur des
compétences scientifiques de très haut
niveau qui répondront aux enjeux de
demain en particulier la transition
écologique et la révolution numérique je
voudrais mentionner deux points qui sont
susceptibles d'attirer votre attention
d'une part la création de clubs de
mathématiques dans les collèges la
multiplication de ces clubs de
mathématiques qui favorisent une
pratique collégiale et souvent ludique
des mathématiques sous l'égide du
mathématicien Hugo Dumesnil copain
médaille fiels d'autre part
l'introduction d'une heure et demie de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun des
élèves de première à compter de la
terminale concernant l'orientation des
fils l'objectif est d'atteindre 50% de
filles dans les principales spécialités
scientifiques de la voix générale à
l'horizon du quinquennat je suis donc
plus que favorable à votre résolution
qui permettra de renforcer encore la
dynamique dans laquelle nous sommes
engagés merci
je vais m'attendre donner la parole à
notre collègue Charles Guénet oui
sénateur